though it's a dream I never could have
had now it's a dream other girls can
grow up in half she was met with
skepticism on both levels and I'm really
over time not perseverance and that
passion earned her the respect of
everybody around her I can show these
guys what you know that you can overcome
any limitations I'm 5 230 pounds I never
should have been able to do what I was
doing even in the women's league so it's
not always about out begging somebody
sometimes you have to be a little bit
smarter
I love work because obviously she's
worked her butt off to getting where she
is
so she's gonna steal even a half of that
into the players and definitely what
happens